when you first step into the wind tunnel
it's a weird feeling because one moment
you're on the ground and next moment
you're out in the air
i always see things that give me
exhilaration it never was scary and it
was more something really really fun
this great big story is made possible by
lego play her way
[Music]
i'm kirapo and i'm an indoor skydiver i
have 33 medals and i also have three
guinness world records and in 2017 i was
named the fastest flyer
indoor skydiving is a free-fall
simulator and it simulates outdoor
skating and it's a sport that i've been
doing for close to nine years
my parents are my biggest supporters i
chanced upon indus driving because my
mom was helping i fly to the
advertisements so they needed people to
film but once i stepped into the wind
tunnel i knew that it was immediately
something that i wanted to do i always
wanted to be an astronaut because it
gave me the ability to fly but after
discovering this spot it became my
passion
[Music]
for indoor skydiving there's many
different categories i mainly focus on
two solo freestyle and two-way dynamic
so for two-way dynamics you have to make
a routine and go as fast as possible and
the fastest time will win
and for freestyle it's more about
creativity like a dance so they are
judged on presentation execution and
technicality
because endless diving is an extreme
sport we need to keep our body in shape
and fit so i usually do gym or hot yoga
or i even do a trampoline park because
it's something that simulates the indoor
tunnel and how we fly
so i wake up at around 6 20 for school
and i finish around 5 30 or 6 30 and
then i would eat my dinner in the car
because i wouldn't have enough time and
i'll go to ifly singapore to start
training so i'll start training from
around seven to ten and i will go back
home and start doing my work at eleven
and sometimes end at two or three am
and then it just continues over and over
again
[Music]
i'm really close to my sister and we do
everything together she also tried this
sport and she got into it as well she's
only nine years old but she's an amazing
rock star and i really enjoy coaching
her and seeing her improve i was
recently awarded the class a spotter
which means that i was an instructor and
could now coach the younger children
it's really fun to see them improving
because when i was young i really
enjoyed learning from other people and i
hope that i can help inspire them too
[Music]
when i first started out there was not
many female flyers because it was a
mainly men dominated sport if i were to
give any advice to any young female
athletes i'll just say try your best and
bring 100 into what you love to do